hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to oxygen not included
now I always die when the temperature
gets too high that is the thing that
always kills me no matter what it always
gets to me so in this episode I am going
to solve the crisis of the temperature
once and for all before it ends my very
existence I will not allow it to end MO
I will not allow this heat nightmare to
end my entire existence no I will cut it
off at the pass I will not allow it to
get to me because I am good at games I
am good at the game playing I've played
games and I've played them goodly and I
will not be any different in this game
here ok so if I need to solve this water
crisis I'm thinking what I gotta do is I
gotta try to find a nice biome I mean
that's the only thing that makes sense
to me
right now at this juncture so if I need
to find a nice biome that means I need
to go in the statistically most likely
way that I'm gonna find some ice and cuz
if I can find some ice volume then I'm
gonna have an unlimited amount of ice
then I can have all these things out
running I want then I can cool it down
no matter what I can bring that in so
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna create
some airlocks just have a kind of a
double airlock thing going on because I
always like it with a deodorizer I don't
know if that's gonna help but I'm gonna
basically do that and we're just gonna
go straight out two by two and that's it
hey we'll get some coal on the way too
which is cold well we need because
that's the only thing that we're gonna
use to our this kind of thing even
though for some reason we don't have any
coal in this and even though it's a
priority and even though it's a priority
and even though it's a priority and even
though it's priority and even those
priority and even though it's a priority
and even though it's priority and even
though it's priority even though it's
priority it doesn't seem to be something
that's actually happening look gold old
dumpling I love you but you ain't doing
it right
good old dumpling what's even that hat
that you got going on that's that's the
ranching hat why don't you have the
farming hat
No aah
damn it I didn't mean to click that I
meant to aah I didn't mean to click
Danny I didn't mean to click that slump
Oh what are you even doing with your
life
sorry slump oh you're gonna be carrying
stuff
you're good you're carrying kind of
person evil baby face what are you even
doing with your life nothing all right
you're gonna be carrying mm-hmm
someone's got to be farming good old
dumplings farming that's all that's all
we need okay all right but no matter it
doesn't wow man whoever digs they're
really good at digging okay what have we
got going on here okay whoo - gazers
wonder what those geysers are all about
maybe hydrogen given that there's
hydrogen over here mmm one of this one
might be steamed given the water mm-hmm
maybe oh [ __ ] water it won't stop me I'm
unstoppable
I can always go up a step I guess boom
there we go
problem solved perfect love it that
chlorine that's not good wait no hang on
a second wait no chlorines not good wait
a minute these are gonna be here there's
gonna be some airflow here problem
solved forever problem solved forever do
I need more duplicants as if I've got
plenty of oxygen and I've got plenty of
food then I should be able to sustain
more duplicants right right right
shouldn't should I have more duplicates
should I have more I usually get to the
problem where I have too many and then
that's no good but right now I seem to
have two too many I'm gonna get one more
we're gonna get up to ten even though I
don't have 10 for the distribution of
the correct number of Armant here I
could always put another level below it
I guess yeah that'd be fine I'll
probably do that but whatever it doesn't
matter that's chlorines getting in our
base this chlorine keeping in our base
that's not good wait Aang good that's
now what you want to see my van can't
clean chlorine that chlorines oh god I
forgot bleach stone just creates oh god
no this is a mistake oh why did I go
through here oh I could have contained
literally any other location but this
job I don't know how to vexes
vixx's Oh God cuz that's just gonna
create more chlorine the bleach stone
that all that's all that do oh god its
little skulls oh oh no well I think it's
fine if a little chlorine is in my base
I don't think that's too much of a
problem because chlorines real heavy and
that means chlorines gonna fall down to
the bottom it's not even gonna be a
problem not even gonna worry about it
because it's not a problem why would it
be a problem not a problem guessing I
don't need these sinks anymore now that
we got sinks there so I think we'll be
fine without sinks for right now and
then I can add more chairs for the other
duplicates that are gonna come by oh god
that just released more bleach stone
oh no oh somehow that's worse somehow
I've made it even worse are you know
what fine fine you know what I'm not
even gonna deal with you I'm gonna leave
the doors open cuz they need to breathe
in there anyway so I might as well just
push oxygen in cuz I bet my oxygen is
gonna win this fight and then I can push
chlorine down here and compress it a
little bit with the amount of oxygen I
mean there's just more oxygen up here so
it's a good thing it's a good thing okay
speed it up a little more how we doing
I'm down temperature Oh something up
there okay for some reason and I don't
know why but it just gets colder around
we're geysers are they chained then they
take out the ice biome is it only heat
biome I've got is I only have heat and
they it didn't expect that
okay whatever it's fine what is it not
me
certainly not me we're all fine how's
the temperature doing bad good mmm
that's too spicy that's a little too
spicy
why is there water here with this water
come from who peed pure pristine water
all over the place here I'm just setting
up some temporary beds for people to
have once once we get that all in order
maybe I'll just extend it out one more
over and then I could have three and
then I'd have 12 and I think 12 is a
pretty cool number but then it's really
warm over there and I don't want to
infect the warmness so I bet I better
just build it down
now that I think about it now that I've
thunked a little more about it I could
probably do that and that might be a
little bit better there's still no ice
oh no we have got nowhere in this
adventure we have done nothing did they
take out the ice biome oh I bet they did
oh I bet they did they thought it was
overpowered and now we don't need it
anymore now No okay it's fine because I
say it's fine and if I say it's fine
that means it's fine um Oh new friend
new friend who do we got Otto ask an
auto bore mate we could have a chef
you'd actually have a ship
Otto without Otto slicka t-rex oh yeah
my mom calls me Otto my friends call me
slick ax T Ragnar the gray okay slick in
Iraq I am sleepy rag now the great your
name is too big Ragnar the Great and I
literally can't say anything besides
your full entire name slick dear AG now
the great dear AG now the great alright
um I suppose I could put some decorum in
here that might be nice mmm that's nice
why is there water in here oh the sink
oh that's right okay that makes sense
it's still water just here but I'm just
gonna destroy it and get water
everywhere anyway because I'm an [ __ ]
that's where the whoa oh now it makes
I get it now I'm an a-hole
oh I get it
oh I get it okay well anyway hey we've
got new friends slicky Ragnar the great
hey you like carrying I thought you
liked cooking didn't you like cooking I
thought you liked cooking yeah whatever
man carrying that's all I need from you
carry there we go
okay improve carrying good job there
buddy you're gonna be carrying the team
on your back okay how are we doing over
here all right so far so okay six
temperatures kind of going down that way
but I don't know if that's actually an
indication that anything's good we now
have access to another ocean for
whatever that's worth and I'm pretty
sure it's not worth very much hey slick
kitty Ragnar the great do you know where
your bed is we're slick at here Akbar
the great little eating just look at he
what solidity your is clearly right here
comfy bed you don't need a comfy bed you
need this bed how do you have food
poisoning
what are you food poisoning what did you
do slicky Ragnar the gree you didn't
even get any sleep you so dumb
okay temperatures oh no oh no that
that's the beginning of the end this is
the beginning of the end if I cannot get
that I'm sorry I still think it's the
beginning at the end it's the beginning
at the end we need to turn some of these
off it is where it all goes wrong I
swear this is where it all starts to go
horribly wrong I know this to be true
but hey we got a lot of water that's
good okay so that's gonna be the last of
the stuff that we produce in there all
very good might be a bit of trouble okay
we gotta get the temperature down how do
we get the temperature down I mean the
only thing we have are these icy fans
but they're not actually doing anything
good because I mean it's just it's it's
just not gonna really be enough I mean
it's trying to pump colder air through
here but even that air is still kind of
toasty the only way that I know to cool
things down is to would be to put more
there but I don't have enough ice to
make enough
and I'm just making more and more heat
no matter what I do it's not like I have
enough ice anyway let me try an
experiment I'm gonna put these at level
seven and these at level six
just because I'm wondering what will
happen
over time if we just have a lot of
people on these utilities and we have a
couple more so right now the imminent
threat is the heat death of our universe
so if there's not even enough oxygen
here to supply that wet where's all my
oxygen going why is it all pumping out
all right turn them all on it turn them
all on I guess we are producing a lot of
co2 I guess this should be enough to
offset it now whatever it'll start up
more soon yeah I think it's getting
better yeah that'll that should be
enough it's not enough and be bad hey
we've actually made quite a bit more
water we've actually we're actually
doing pretty good on the water
generation I'm kind of surprised we're
doing shockingly good on the water
generation long commutes yeah we're
starting to get along commutes now I
think it's just a factor of wow that's a
lot that's so much water
that's so much water what you said that
there were gonna be oceans in here I
didn't think you literally meant that
they were gonna be oceans so water I
can't Jules how am I gonna be able to
use that one it's so much water yet
nothing I can use what do you do you've
created lettuce
lettuce crunchy slightly salty leaves
from the water we'd plan quality
terrible calories 400 oh no new new new
new new friend new friend yes add to the
problem
I just want specialized people sorry
goodbye I'm taking these I don't want to
add too many too quick oh it's the
beginning of the end this is beginning
at the end it's beginning in the end
it's beginning in the end it's the
beginning of the end it's the beginning
at the end oh it's the beginning at the
end it's the beginning at the end
oh it's the beginning in the end in the
end it's so the beginning at the end
it's the beginning at the end it's just
the beginning of the and II it's plainly
the beginning at the end it's the
beginning at the end like it's just the
beginning at the end it's the beginning
at the end I can't state how much this
is in fact at the beginning in the end
it's just plain old the beginning at the
end it's just like this I can fight it
if I it's not the beginning at the end
why is there carbon dioxide here mr.
carbon dioxide there that's bizarre
okay I don't know why that is I would
feel like this should be getting a
little more than this I'm gonna make
this permeable okay temperature is not
really dropping oh wait these got
buildable so that's pretty good maybe I
need to build a lot more ice machines
that's probably gonna help me fight the
beginning of the end I bet I'm willing
to bed that's gonna help me fight past
the beginning of the end so if I can
stop the beginning of the end then it'll
be the end of the beginning and then it
won't be the beginning of the end
okay so the answer is there's neutronium
over here so there was nothing over here
so that is the limit of the rightmost
area I don't know if there would be a
douche and put a notion above me but it
sure looks like they've done that so
nevermind they're a douche but it is
getting colder here it is a little bit
colder here that's still too warm all
this is starting to get a little too
warm why it it's not that bad it's
pretty bad so how do I fix this how do I
make it not
roasty roast how can it possibly not get
roasty toasty in here that's that's what
I'm hoping
understand this is 62° that's so hot
it's so much heat and then this is not
enough heat dissipation it's getting a
little better here especially it's
getting a little better it's not like a
lot better but I don't know if I have
enough ice to really like get to all
these points but now I've got six ice
makers so that's something they don't
take too much power they generate a lot
of heat and I mean a lot of heat but
it's better than nothing I guess it's
better than nothing yeah it's probably
better than nothing it's a little better
than nothing okay now oxygen is doing
pretty good but for some reason these
things aren't able to are unable to take
in as much carbon dioxide as I would
like they seem to be nowhere to turn at
this entry
hey we made it to a hundred cycles hey
guys
that's pretty good that's surprisingly
pretty good hey we're not dead yet so
that's pretty good oh hell yeah crank
those things oh that's so smart he picks
up the water that he's done with and
puts them in the plants and then the
cold cold water is gonna cool down the
plant it's so smart oh it's so smart and
generally I think overall we're kind of
doing a little bit better I don't know
if it's a perfect distribution but it
looks to me like for at least a little
bit here well two of them they got
better cure sick duplicate of disease
ooh
nice power wasted a lot probably from
all the coal okay but oxygen is going
better the temperature is not perfect
it's still very warm but oh is that
still going wait are we still making
mush mush for not don't make mush stop
stop that stop we don't need to make
mush we got plenty of food that's not
mush
what I should do is I should have this
door right here instead I don't like it
but you know just cuz it's in walking
distance makes it a little bit easier
less of a commute that one's getting up
to 85 degrees Celsius that's really hot
that one right there that one's getting
real toasty I don't know if I should
have like made a little bit more of a
gap between them and my my environment
but it doesn't seem to be bleeding
through that badly
oddly enough so I think that this
process of cooling things down is
actually not doing too
terrible and this is getting nice and
chilled oh that's cold
doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo how am I
gonna get this water out of here I guess
I'm just gonna dump it
I guess what I could use if I make mesh
tiles right here and I just crack the
egg it will flow out and down there I I
mean that's that's what would happen I
don't know if that's the best choice but
that is definitely what would happen you
know maybe that's you know screw it
let's do it oh no not yet no hurry hurry
hurry me mommy mommy mommy mommy mommy
about yes meemaw what's the save oh I
forgot about that
hey whatever it's fine all right me Mom
with the save okay cool uh put some nice
tile on the ground II tile or donkus go
incus Shawa going cos donkus doing kiddo
incus put a sink there go incus what a
bed there and there there and then a
turlet right there there and then pipe
it up
there we go so for the first time in a
long time we have more water than we
need juice
beginning at the end beginning at the
end beginning in the end beginning at
the end beginning of the Hassan you
looked great
just because you fall asleep doesn't
mean we don't need you in here right now
that thing looks dead nothing was so
dead
hey you or as I like to call you must
have known that people like me you know
idiots like to just name their character
sets it's so sprung go welcome aboard
scrum go hey welcome hey scrum go I look
hey you like cooking sprung go is gonna
be our cook scrum go listen you're a
good cook and these fine folks deserve
some nice good food so that's what
you're gonna get you like that scrum go
now listen scrum go you're gonna do me
proud and you're gonna do this family
proud by giving us all your all and then
you you're gonna get you're gonna get
what you deserve which is love and
affection put these here toodaloo this
is going great he's going so good
I love the little Wow
they're so cute this so cute hey good
Hey look at this we don't have to run
this the whole time cuz we don't
actually have all this such a good day
we actually somehow ran ourselves out of
that that's good it's good it's a good
thing it's a good thing guys
so we now don't have to worry about the
water problem because our water is doing
a clean delicious water there is no
water that is cleaner that is more pure
than the water that is in the Pigpen
colony I understand your hesitancy about
the name Pigpen
oh listen that is not in any way
reflective on the colony as a whole this
colony is a delight and I am delighted
to delight in it's delectable delight
how's the temperature Gouda it's getting
better it's getting better every day so
that's good this is bad but because of
this insulating tile here it's never
gonna affect us problem-solve forever
colony warming it's just a myth it's
something perpetuated by just a bunch of
people who don't know what they're
talking about this colony is nice and
cold look at it pure clean cold air you
can't believe it negative 32 kb to use
that's a lot of KD to use I don't like
the water just kind of leaks out of them
but you know whatever it's cold water
it's better it's good it's a good thing
so having been on the verge of collapse
I think we actually have kind of averted
disaster for just even a little bit of
time it's not perfect by any means
I know stretch of the imagination do I
think that we have solved this problem
however we have done adequately to slow
down what was previously inevitable so
that is something whether or not this is
gonna continue on for the duration of my
time here who's to say but for now it's
good and we've welcomed two new members
to the colony strong go and drag Lea
Ragnar the boo there was a slicka T
Ragnar the
great of course how could I forget mr.
the great obviously you are too great to
even possibly remotely forget about okay
flooding flooding flooding oh that's not
flooding come on get over yourself
that's barely flooding we're gonna
destroy these now cuz we don't need
those there and you're gonna go to where
scrum go scrum go we know scrum goes
look at he recognized the great ah there
we go and then we got room for one more
and I probably will have one more it
never stops can't believe I'm saying it
but hey I think I'm gonna live for a few
more so cool I've got this weird thing
that feels a lot like hope in my heart
so that's a new sensation that's
sweeping the nation
okay next project that I'm gonna do is
ambitious to say the least but I think
it can work what I'm gonna try to do is
I'm gonna try to create a single ocean I
call it my flat ocean theory I think
that if i play my cards right I can
punch a hole in all of these oceans and
get it into one big huge ocean now even
just saying that makes my heart drop
because I'm like all I'm doing is I'm
creating the recipe for my own disaster
but imagine if we had just one big
beautiful ocean right I know terrible
terrible idea but I'm gonna do it anyway
because I am an adventurer and I boldly
go where no one has ever gone before and
I bet one time is more than enough to
hold back the might of this ocean I'm
gonna put him there yet you know what
actually why am i digging out the abyss
like that's a perfect wall for my ocean
you know what I'm actually and I wish I
didn't dig out that abyss like that
would be a perfect wall for my ocean
let's think about it like that the abyss
alight is a good ol
not perfect but my phone fell out of my
pocket you're gonna be the base of the
bowl
for now you're gonna be a secondary wall
for the bowl this is grand project time
look at what I'm about to accomplish I
feel this yeah yeah yeah new test
subject
listen oh nevermind mockery I don't need
muck fruit
you can't build ha Harold from wig ffred
Kerry Bravo why am i drawn to names the
end didn't bow I can't name everything
like that no no no you're gonna be tiny
sad sack I don't make fun of his tiny
sad sack know I ever come up with my own
name call you your knee you know I'm
horny you're and stay away from poor
knee your knee whatever you do stay away
from all horny you're definitely not a
good forlorn
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not funny I don't know why that's
funny to me because it's not it's not
funny I don't find it funny at all okay
so this is like this is a stupid project
by the way can I just admit that this is
just a terribly stupid project and I am
aware of the fact that is a terribly
stupid project however when you give me
a place with a bunch of oceans the first
thing I want to do is poke a hole in
them and drain them all into one place I
just do it's the only thing I want in
life ever I don't know why I need it but
I know I need it I know that what you
just did you just you all right
two can play this game is trap you could
chew over there good thing I was here to
see it okay so with the temperature
problem moderately postponed for now the
temperature is going down shockingly it
is going down but that's only because
I've got such a high priority on these
things but then again the ice is only
ready you know so often so I guess it
kind of balances out but the temperature
problem is fine for now we've got 12
beautiful people and we've got horny
horny in here so that's good so we're
gonna let bygones be bygones and we're
just going to eventually make everything
good I want to eventually I want to
remake the base that I have got I know
it's like tough to do considering I
created like some water-based
necessities for the shape of it but I
feel like I could make it a lot more
efficient if I didn't have everything on
different horizontal like vertical
levels of had everything horizontal but
that's stretch goal after my ocean
adventure oh hell oh don't do that
everything's looking your knee for me
anyway
I'm gonna get out of here before I cause
any more horrible problems which I will
I will cause all of the problems made
what why why what mee-mah mee-mah
mee-mah remark red alert
all red alert alert okay red alert over
go to bed me Mom go to bed no got
riddler real hard thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]